JOINING US TO DISCUSS THE LEGAL
ISSUES BEHIND ALL THIS, NORM
EISEN, SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN
TRUMP'S FIRST IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
NORM, FIRST OF ALL, I WONDER IF
YOU COULD CLEAR UP, BY LAW, WHO
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO SUCH
OFFICES AND VOTING SYSTEMS?
IS THE LAW CLEAR ON THIS?
>> JIM, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK.
THE LAW MAKES CLEAR AND IT'S
THE -- IT STARTS WITH GEORGIA
STATE LAW ON COMPUTER TRESPASS
AND COMPUTER INVASION OF
PROPERTY, THAT ONLY AUTHORIZED
INDIVIDUALS ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS.
SO NOW THAT WE HAVE THIS
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE, IT RAISES
A AR
A VERY SERIOUS QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER UNAUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS
GOT ACCESS TO THE DATA.
THERE IS ALSO FEDERAL STATUTES
THAT ARE INVOLVED, THERE IS
PERSONAL INFORMATION, VERY
SENSITIVE ON THESE SYSTEMS.
SO THIS RAISES VERY SERIOUS
LEGAL ISSUES.
>> NORM, WE JUST HEARD DREW
EXPLAINING TO US, YOU KNOW, YES,
THERE ARE STATE BY STATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
BUT IT IS JUST NOT CLEAR IF DOJ
IS PURSUING ANY BROADER
INVESTIGATION, RIGHT, THAT THEY
HAVE GOTTEN THIS STATE
INFORMATION, BUT THERE HAS BEEN
NO RESPONSE IN RETURN AS DREW
SAID.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
D.A. IN FULTON COUNTY, GEORGIA,
FANI WILLIS, IS DOING IN THAT,
YOU KNOW, BROADENING PROBE INTO
CRIMINAL PROBE INTO EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION, HOW
WOULD THIS ALSO TAKE IN PLACE IN
GEORGIA IN A DIFFERENT COUNTY,
HOW MIGHT THIS IMPACT THAT?
>> WELL, POPPY, THERE IS
INDICATIONS THAT SOME OF THE
PLANNING AND EXECUTION OF THIS
EVENT TOOK PLACE WITHIN AND
USING SOME OF THE CONTRACTORS
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED, TOOK
PLACE WITHIN FULTON COUNTY,
WITHIN FANI WILLIS'
JURISDICTION.
SO THAT ALLOWS HER TO
INVESTIGATE THESE MATTERS.
THERE IS SERIOUS ONES UNDER
GEORGIA LAW, AND, YOU KNOW, YOU
SEE THE -- THE SAME CAST OF
CHARACTERS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SO INTERESTING
THAT MISS LATHAM IS ALSO A FAKE
ELECTOR.
WE KNOW SHE IS LOOKING
INTENSIVELY AT THAT, THERE IS A
GRAND JURY IN D.C., A FEDERAL
GRAND JURY THAT IS LOOKING AT
THE FAKE ELECTORS.
SO THIS IS ALREADY WITHIN MISS
WILLIS' JURISDICTION, AND I
WOULD BE VERY SURPRISED IF THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES DIDN'T ALSO
LOOK, UNDER FEDERAL COMPUTER
HACKING, INTRUSION AND INVASION
STATUTES AT WHETHER THERE WERE
FEDERAL ISSUES HERE AS WELL.
>> NORM, THERE IS THE CONTINUING
QUESTION WITH ALL THE CASES AS
TO WHETHER THE LEGAL SYSTEM IS
KEEPING UP WITH THIS, RIGHT?
AND WITH WHAT LEVEL OF SPEED AND
SERIOUSNESS.
THIS IS IN GEORGIA, BUT AS DREW
MADE THE POINT, SIMILAR ACCESS
OCCURRED IN OTHER STATES WHICH
COULD POINT, RIGHT, TO THERE
BEING A BROADER PLAN, CONSPIRACY
OF WHICH THERE IS EVIDENCE,
RIGHT?
THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENT, FORMER
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS AND SO ON.
IN YOUR VIEW, DOES IT NEED TO BE
A NATIONAL INVESTIGATION TO SOME
DEGREE?
>> JIM, I THINK WE HAVE SEEN
THAT WITH THE WORK OF THE
GEORGIA D.A., THERE IS A RULE
FOR STATE INVESTIGATORS HERE.
SHE IS OUT IN FRONT OF EVERYONE
INVESTIGATING THE ALLEGED CRIMES
COMMITTED BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS INVOLVED
WITH HIM.
SO, WHILE YOU NEED A STRONG
STATE REVIEW, YES, THERE IS A
ROLE FOR A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THERE ARE MULTIPLE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION, FOR EXAMPLE, INTO
THE FAKE ELECTORS, WE KNOW THAT
EXISTS, WE KNOW THERE IS A GRAND
JURY, BECAUSE OF THE PRESENCE OF
FAKE ELECTOR, ALLEGEDLY AS PART
OF THIS, AND, AGAIN WE HAVE TO
NOTE HER ATTORNEY SAYS THERE WAS
NO WRONGDOING, WE'LL SEE,
BECAUSE OF HER PRESENCE, THAT
FEDERAL GRAND JURY COULD BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE THIS AND
PROBABLY SHOULD BE.
>> NORM EISEN, THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US UNDERSTAND IT.
>> THANKS, POPPY.
THANKS, JIM.